bonjour à merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors le ministère
de l'intérieur a publié un cd hier la
nouvelle version complète du schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre bobo
d'ailleurs parle pas d'une nouvelle
version mais d'une nouvelle mouture
finalement idée à quoi de nouveau
les phrases bonjour les phrases sont
changés on a changé les moments n'a pas
changé le contenu la nasse est toujours
autorisé toujours la libre appréciation
à de l'arbitraire de l'état eh bien on
arrive à quelque chose ou toujours
aujourd'hui il ya une responsabilité
collective des manifestants d'être
présent cirque on as tout le monde et on
tape dans le tarn donc en fait on n'a
rien changé on a juste mis un nouveau
vernis mêlant le contenu de l'emballage
est le même oui d'ailleurs donc elle
vous le désir la technique de la masse
est maintenu un seulement si elle est
proportionnée nécessaire mais c'est
justement ça le fait qu'elle soit pas
forcément proportionnées et nécessaires
qui posait problème a déjà même de base
l'ananas devrait pas exister elle avait
été supprimée en france depuis 1934 il
ya eu des morts 15 morts à l'époque du
coup on avait dit ça ne va pas ce que
cela le fait de nas et les gens c'est un
effet psychologique qui engendre de la
violence qui engendre des dégâts
supplémentaires donc en fait menacer
déjà est un échec deuxième chose c'est
qu'on a dit leur est la gestion de la
manifestation doit se faire par la
violence la répression policière de
l'état policier pour être exact parce
que c'est ce qu'on constate une fois de
plus aujourd'hui c'est pas les policiers
qui choisissent le cadre légal dans
lequel ils veulent agir mais c'est bien
les politiques qui sont responsables des
agissements des policiers sur le terrain
et l'autre chose donc sur ce cadre c'est
que effectivement là il y aurait pu y
avoir des des services de renseignement
renforcée il y aurait pu avoir de la
prévention il y aura pu avoir de la
désescalade de la violence comme
d'autres pays européens savent le faire
la france a choisi la voie de la
violence de la répression et ce qui
permet au gouvernement en général de ne
pas avoir à répondre politiquement aux
aspirations de la rue lui qu'il préfère
envoyer la police et les gendarmes alors
cette technique on le rappelle avait
initialement été jugée illégale par le
conseil d'état et finalement il revient
en dessus pourquoi finalement
un faudra demander aux gens du conseil
d'état mais les garanties qui sont
proposés proportionnelle et ses étangs à
la libre appréciation de la hiérarchie
policière ça pose des difficultés
surtout que la hiérarchie policière par
exemple j'ai pensé sur paris c'est le
ministre canaux mais le préfet de police
donc à aujourd'hui monsieur l'allemand
qui avait été choisi pour ses très bons
résultats de répression à bordeaux donc
en fait c'est pas monsieur l'allemand ou
des préfets de ce type là qui vont
donner des ordres cohérent et en
adéquation avec ce qu'on peut attendre
d'une démocratie et d'une république
telles que la france donc à partir de là
pour le moment on n'a rien changé on est
toujours sur le même schéma et même pire
que ça c'est dire qu'en fait ce schéma
de mccann lords où tous coupables dans
la manifestation c'est le schéma des
lois par exemple qui avait été mis en
place sous mussolini en italie à
l'époque et ce qui veut dire qu'on
arrive en disant vous êtes dans la
manifestation vous êtes tous coupables
alors qu'en france normalement chacun
responsable de son propre fait chacun
devrait avoir une prise en charge
individuelle et c'est eux conception du
maintien de l'ordre continuaient
d'engendrer des violences des blessés à
la fois du côté des policiers et des
manifestants voire des riffs rats et
n'aura rien réglé du tout comme problème
à part peut-être arranger les politiques
actuelles au pouvoir qui évite tous les
problèmes de fond et les problèmes posés
par les français qui ne sont pas écoutés
alors on le rappelle un policier a écopé
d'une amende de 1500 euros je crois à
prévoir a blessé un manifestant avec un
tir de l bd une manifestation de jd
jaune lbd aussi mans tenue quelle
lecture en faites vous mais noël et
bédié n'est pas du tout une arme
approprié pour la manifestation c'est
une arme déjà qui est pas assez précises
dans une manifestation dans un cadre
précis face à une foule face à une foule
qui est nécessaire ce serait plutôt des
canons à eau des personnels humain sur
le terrain on a voulu remplacer les
êtres humains par justement des ailes bd
qui blessent qui mutile et plus donc à
partir de là ce n'était qu'une mauvaise
idée c'est un mauvais signal donc du
coup les canons à eau sont pas forcément
renforcée donc dépenser de l'argent où
il ya besoin ya des choses qui peuvent
être mis en place la france fait un
autre choix également le choix de cet
armement plutôt que de la prévention
avec des services de renseignement
pertinent et performant à dialogue avec
les manifestants donc une fois ci nous
fait plus on choisit le choix
technologique de la répression plutôt
que le côté humain et relations pour que
ça se déroule correctement alors
justement vous voir les ne signale
qu'elle signale justement avec ce
nouveau schéma national du maintien de
l'ordre qu'elle est et quel est le
message que le gouvernement a voulu
faire passer
le même que d'habitude c'est dire on a
fait n'importe quoi jusqu'ici on à
réprimer toute manifestation quelles
qu'elles soient du moment qu'ils
s'opposent au gouvernement aux continue
voilà on change de 3 mo à la marge mais
le fond du problème va être le même on
va coacher li mais ce que les braves m
vont être dissolue non on n'en a pas
parlé non plus je rappelle que c'est la
résurgence des voltigeurs que même
charles pasqua avait dissout à l'époque
en 1986
on est toujours sur ce schéma ultra
violent ultra répressif alors qu'on voit
bien que d'autres pays peuvent faire
différemment et ce qui a été rappelé
dans le reportage juste avant l'onu
avait bien précisé que la france avait
quand même une gestion très particulière
du maintien de l'ordre
finalement le beauvau de la sécurité
aura servi à quoi
à faire de la communication de la
propagande pour le gouvernement parce
qu'il n'en est rien sorti de ce bourg ou
la sécurité les principales intéressées
en dehors des policiers des gendarmes
qui n'ont pas pu s'exprimer parce que
leur parole a été muselé par différentes
sanctions contre les policiers lanceur d
alerte au sein de la police nationale
les citoyens usagers du service public
de la sécurité ont été exclues n'ont pas
pu s'exprimer également donc en fait
c'était juste un plébiscite de la parole
gouvernementale qui n'a mené à rien du
tout à part juste à cette relecture de
copies ou on est en train de changer des
points virgules plutôt que de changer la
philosophie de fond de ce qui devrait
être un maintien de l'ordre dans une
république telles que la france
alexandre langlois merci d'avoir répondu
à nos questions je rappelle que vous
êtes policier candidat déclaré à la
présidence de la république au sein du
mouvement refondations 2022 merci à vous